sé que a veces parezco demasiado
apasionado sé que a muchos de ustedes no
les gusta eso pero esta lección no se
trata de mí se trata de vos esta lección
se trata de Si queremos seguir por este
rumbo que hace décadas nos conduce al
fracaso o si queremos hacer algo
distinto punto y aparte
[Música]
Javier Gerardo miraiza ha convertido en
el fenómeno político del momento ojo no
solo en la Argentina su Victoria las
pasó lo ha catapultado a nivel
internacional Ahora son muchos quienes
quieren sacar tajada de su victoria de
una u otra forma López Obrador evocó los
fantasmas de Hitler nazismo al explicar
El Triunfo de Miley el bolsonarismo
celebró la victoria de Miley en las paso
puede ser el cambio real que la
Argentina necesita por primera vez un
candidato libertario tiene serias
posibilidades de hacerse con la
presidencia de un país como la Argentina
si el fenómeno Miley era una incógnita y
una simple manifestación de hartazgo
cansancio y enfado tras las paso se ha
convertido en una opción de gobierno
totalmente real el banco de Wall Street
que anticipa un triunfo de Miley en las
elecciones presidenciales según Wells
Fargo el candidato liberal tiene 65% de
ser electo presidente este año Javier
Miley anticipó que lo contactaron del
fmi y en los próximos días se reunirán
ahora bien Cómo surgió semejante o la
libertaria en el país a 8 de dónde viene
y qué posiciones tiene Exactamente mi
ley Cuál es su plan para la Argentina
queridos amigos amigas En este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas vamos a descubrir Qué hay tras
el Tsunami mi ley arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos pese a sus Grandes Ideas
y venidas en materia económica la
política Argentina ha tenido en cierto
modo un hilo conductor más o menos
constante en la primera parte del siglo
XX con la consolidación democrática
surgió la unión cívica radical el primer
gran partido de masas que de hecho ganó
las tres primeras elecciones abiertas
las de 1916 las del 22 y las del 28
luego las fuerzas armadas se metieron de
lleno en la vida con el golpe de 1930 Y
a partir de ese momento digamos que la
democracia Argentina fue intermitente
los golpes de estado se sucedieron y
durante años la democracia se limitó a
determinados periodos de tiempo Pues
bien en uno de esos espacios surgió
precisamente Juan Domingo perón Quien
fundó el movimiento peronista y sentó
las bases de lo que sería a partir de
entonces la democracia Argentina de esta
forma por un lado tenemos el anti
peronismo habitualmente vinculado a la
unión cívica radical y otros partidos
aliados y por otro al peronismo
sostenido principalmente por el partido
justicialista Pues bien ya lo tenemos
Este es el tándem que desde el regreso a
la democracia en 1983 ha dominado por
completo La Argentina en la última
década este dueto ha estado representado
en sus distintos nombres por la
coalición opositora Juntos por el cambio
y por la coalición oficialista peronista
unión por la patria Y así fue hasta que
una tercera fuerza biohueco y de repente
se coló en la política de un país con
una economía absolutamente devastada por
supuesto como no estamos hablando de la
libertad avanza el partido político de
Javier Miley
en las paso de 2023 los libertarios no
solo lograron una victoria nacional sin
precedentes sino que además obtuvieron
una enorme cantidad de votos en el
interior del país en provincias y
municipios que eran Auténticos bastiones
peronistas de hecho tanto en la capital
Federal como en la propia provincia de
Buenos Aires Juntos por el cambio y
unión por la patria lograron retener su
caudal de votos es decir que Javier
Miley logró su triunfo nacional gracias
sobre todo a sus victorias en lugares
donde ningún detractor del peronismo
había logrado semejante hazaña por lo
menos en las últimas cinco décadas pero
ahora bien cuál fue exactamente la
ventana de oportunidad que aprovechó mi
ley como demonios logró generar
semejante vorágine electoral un tipo que
llegó a la política en 2019 Estas son
las dos primeras preguntas que tenemos
que responder antes de ver exactamente
qué es lo que quiere hacer milai con
Argentina Así que vamos con ello
[Música]
la semilla el desencanto macrista
el corralito y el colapso del 2001
dieron paso a un país donde el tipo de
cambio el último dato de la inflación y
los salarios acaparan una atención
social desmedida Quizás por eso aunque
te pueda resultar extraño en el país de
la eterna crisis en la universidad
Argentina la economía es la titulación
número uno cada año se gradúa en el país
casi 15.000 economistas y la verdad no
resulta sorprendente la constante crisis
ha hecho que la Argentina los temas
económicos acaparen una enorme y
creciente protagonismo político y social
la economía es la auténtica Rockstar del
debate político casi que podríamos decir
que en Argentina en las cenas de Navidad
por ejemplo la inflación es un tema
popular y sabéis que gracias a toda esta
vorágine mediática un buen día encontró
espacio los medios de comunicación un
economista que poco a poco iría
sobresaliendo del montón estamos por
supuesto hablando de Javier milei esto
es del 25 de agosto de 2015 fijaos la
alternativa digamos que digamos en la
que he estado trabajando es en la de
colocar un Bono Sí en dólares que vos lo
escribís en pesos Sí y eso va a permitir
eliminar El Sobrante de dinero poco a
poco hoy Gracias a la campaña de 2015 no
voy con un libertario comenzó a tener
cada vez más y más presencia a los
medios de comunicación por aquella época
mi ley tenían sus intervenciones digamos
un perfil más técnico destacaba sobre
todo por criticar las intervenciones de
precios que había llevado a cabo el
gobierno de Cristina Fernández de
kirchner
[Música]
pero sea como sea el caso es que en esas
elecciones el peronismo perdió Mauricio
macri se convirtió en el nuevo
presidente de Argentina el 10 de
diciembre de ese mismo año las
esperanzas de un gran cambio eran más
que palpables las expectativas estaban
por las nubes seguramente volaban
demasiado altas porque yo hoy estoy acá
Porque creo en ustedes y necesito que
ustedes también crean
[Música]
crean que son capaces de más que pueden
hacer más y merecen vivir mejor un beso
enorme enorme para todos los amo este
país y los amo cada uno de ustedes el
gobierno de macri amigos tuvo que lidiar
con un montón de problemas y entonces en
2016 surgió el debate el gran debate si
el nuevo gobierno debería aplicar una
política de shock o apostar por un
programa gradual que fuese introduciendo
los cambios poco a poco pues bien al
final ganó esta segunda posibilidad en
el intento de buscar una cierta
estabilidad durante la reforma si un
mayor nivel de consenso y paz social
hicieron que el gobierno fuese tan
gradual que al final la mayoría de los
cambios eran apenas perceptibles de esta
forma muy pronto el macrismo incumplió
todas las expectativas que estaban
puestas en esta nueva era al final ni el
gasto público se redujo tanto ni se
terminó con el déficit y tampoco se
aprobó una gran liberalización de la
economía todo seguía más o menos igual
déficit fiscal se cumple la meta Pero un
retrasa el crecimiento el gobierno
mantiene su estrategia de reducción
gradual del rojo presupuestario al que
financia en deuda pero también
condiciona la recuperación de la
actividad en 2017 y sabéis qué fue
Entonces cuando Miley se posicionó como
un referente de todos aquellos que
coincidían con el primer camino y rápido
y a fondo fue aquí cuando nació la
versión más encendida de este candidato
la fórmula que lo llevaría a convertirse
en la tercera vía de la política
Argentina Mireya advirtió que los planes
de ajuste graduales terminan en crisis
de hecho desde mi punto de vista este
gobierno es el socialismo amarillo No yo
no creo que sea un corruptos eh pero se
hizo colectivistas Si les gusta el gasto
público sí digamos o sea le gusta la
intervención del Estado amigos al final
gobierno de macri fue un desastre con la
inflación por las nubes y una malísima
situación económica tuvo que terminar
pidiendo otra vez un rescate al fondo
monetario internacional Así que las
siguientes elecciones pues Volvió el
peronismo y lo hizo además por la puerta
grande ni siquiera les hizo falta llegar
a la segunda vuelta ganaron a la primera
[Música]
en esas elecciones de 2019 ya hubo una
alternativa liberal la de José Luis
expert apenas logró el 1,47% de los
votos pero supuso abrir una ventana que
ya no se cerraría En las siguientes
legislativas esperting y ley lideraron
una alternativa conjunta que sumó casi
1,3 millones de votos los únicos que
estamos proponiendo un cambio de sistema
para que Argentina no sea en el futuro
la villamiseria más grande del mundo
somos nosotros este fue el gran Debut
político de ley que terminó siendo
diputado por la capital Federal con el
17% de los sufragios en total a nivel
nacional la plataforma liberal logró
cuatro diputados y se fue el comienzo Y
a partir de ahí el protagonismo de milei
creció como la espuma con el peronismo
otra vez en el gobierno su mensaje duro
empezó a calar más y más Miley se
convirtió de repente en una de las
principales figuras de la oposición Y
claro con un gobierno tan desastroso y
encima con la pandemia de por medio el
peronismo empezó a deshilacharse por
momentos todo Parecía un auténtico
desastre el escándalo de las vacunas en
Argentina el ministro salud dimite tras
conocerse la vacunación irregular de
funcionarios y otras personalidades
Argentina sigue siendo el peor país en
pasar la pandemia según el ranking de
bloomberg la educación Argentina en su
peor momento a finales del año pasado el
investigador de flaxo Agustín klaus
alertó sobre una proyección que mostraba
que casi 1,5 millones de chicos
abandonaron la escuela después de la
cuarentena y luego llegó la inflación
del 40 al 50 el 80 y hasta el 100% y
también la falta de reservas y toda la
crisis que está atravesando la Argentina
que es de lo que ya os hablamos aquí en
visualpolitik en el vídeo sobre el fin
del peronismo que publicamos hace
algunos días
Argentina empezaba a creer un cambio y
ahora ya había más opciones no había Por
qué limitarse al gradualismo mucha gente
estaba harta y querían un líder firme
Claro y decidido es amigos fue el mejor
caldo de cultivo para que el relato
libertario de milei pudiera cuajar
acá para estar guiando corderos Yo me
metí acá para despertar leones Quiero
escucharlos
[Aplausos]
que es exactamente lo que pasó Miley
empezó a trabajar su candidatura
presidencial en 2022 y apenas Un año más
tarde el resultado estaba servido hoy
nos hemos puesto de pie para decirle
basta al modelo de la decadencia hoy
dimos el primer paso para la
reconstrucción de la Argentina invito a
los argentinos a sumarse la revolución
liberal que va a ser que el 35 años
Argentina vuelva a hacer una potencia
mundial Muchas gracias y vivo La
Libertad
viva la libertad ahora por
supuesto el gran reto son las elecciones
y aquí a diferencia de Juntos por el
cambio el proyecto la libertad avanza
está mucho más cuestionado todo gira en
torno a mi ley un candidato que ahora ya
sí puede reclamarse como el voto útil
contra el peronismo los números de mi
ley dicen que está en disposición de
ganar especialmente si lograra una
segunda vuelta frente al candidato
peronista Sergio massa lo que no parece
un escenario descabellado
[Música]
se da por hecho salvo debacle económica
en los próximos meses que una parte
importante de los votos que en las
primarias fueron a la reta podrían ir no
a burrich sino al candidato peronista si
eso es así bullrich necesitaría
movilizar para sí mismo una gran parte
del voto que no ha participado en las
primarias y la verdad es que no parece
un reto particularmente fácil y eso eso
es lo que explica que Wells Fargo le dé
a un 65% de posibilidades de ser
presidente en cambio Si lograra superar
a masa y pasar a segunda vuelta frente a
Miley entonces la balanza probablemente
se inclinaría hacia la candidata de
Juntos por el cambio en cualquier caso
todo apunta que el organismo lo tiene
muy pero que muy crudo por no decir
imposible todo esto claro y no tiene más
traspiés como este respecto a la venta
de órganos no permitiese esto es que la
cantidad de órganos que va a haber
disponible para salvar gente es menor sí
es menor y porque Dios o sea lo que ya
estaban estaban o sea lo que vos podés
hacer que ahora algunas personas quieren
ingresar si yo digamos O sea a ver es
una decisión mía o sea cómo no voy a
poder decidir sobre mi cuerpo va a
intentar lanzar sus opciones sobre el
voto del miedo y os pregunto no es
darles gasolina sea como sea si algo
está claro Es que hoy por hoy mi ley
tiene muchas probabilidades de terminar
siendo el presidente de la Argentina y
la pregunta lógicamente es Qué planes
tiene En qué se basa La Revolución que
quiere llevar a cabo para volver a
convertir en Argentina en un país rico y
próspero Pues todo tuyo Alberto
gracias Enrique Pues en primer lugar
promete llevar a cabo una gran reforma
del estado se ha comprometido a reducir
el gasto público un 15% de forma
inminente pasar de 18 a 8 el número de
ministerios acabar progresivamente con
los pagos sociales sustituir la obra
pública por concesiones y privatizar
muchas de las empresas que todavía son
propiedad del Estado hablamos por
ejemplo de aerolíneas argentinas o la
petrolera ipf es lo que los libertarios
han denominado como el plan motosierra
Ministerio de turismo y deporte afuera
Ministerio de cultura afuera Ministerio
de ambiente y desarrollo sostenible
afuera Ministerio de las mujeres y
género y diversidad afuera Ministerio de
Obras Públicas afuera aunque te resistas
Pero eso no es todo en paralelo milai
también se ha comprometido a impulsar
una gran reforma de la educación y
también del sistema sanitario la idea
del candidato libertario pasaría por
garantizar el acceso universal a estos
servicios pero cambiando el sistema
actual por uno de seguros en el caso de
la sanidad o cheques vouchers en el caso
de la educación de esta forma los
argentinos recibirían un derecho que
luego podrían canjear por el seguro
médico y los centros educativos que
ellos escogieran de esta forma el modelo
generaría competencia y los actores
privados podrían competir en igualdad y
condiciones con el tiempo se entiende
que recibir el cheque el voucher
educativo o que el estado corriera con
el coste del seguro médico se iría
limitando en función de la renta y así
poco a poco se podría crear un sistema
al que todos tendrían acceso pero que
tendría más competencia mucho menos
coste para las arcas públicas de una
forma de funcionar más eficiente
[Música]
Asimismo Miley ha defendido un millón de
veces el comercio libre y eso es
exactamente lo que quiere para el país
que reduzca todas las barreras posibles
y se abra de forma unilateral al
comercio mundial y luego por supuesto la
que podemos considerar como su propuesta
estrella según mi ley el plan definitivo
para acabar con el Eterno problema de la
inflación en Argentina estamos hablando
por supuesto de la dolarización del país
No solo proponemos una un sistema de
competencia de moneda a la luz de lo que
eligió los argentinos a lo largo de la
historia es el dólar por lo tanto vamos
a liquidar el Banco Central en dólares y
junto a ello Miley también promete
acabar con muchas de las regulaciones
que afectan a la vida económica
Argentina hablamos de regulaciones
laborales regulaciones de precios
regulaciones profesionales o también
impulsar reducciones de impuestos es
decir prácticamente lo que Javier milei
quiere es transformar de arriba a abajo
el sistema productivo del país entonces
la pregunta que tenemos que hacer nos
lógicamente es a ver realmente todo esto
es posible Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
gobernar con motosierra
queridos amigos amigas lógicamente para
llevar a cabo todas las reformas
prometidas por mi ley no solo
necesitaría ganar Las presidenciales
también tendría que conseguir el apoyo
del parlamento El problema es que en
Argentina la renovación de las cámaras
es parcial en cada elección se renueva
la mitad de la cámara de diputados y un
tercio del senado esto quiere decir que
incluso si el partido de milei obtuviera
en la primera vuelta el mismo nivel de
apoyo que en las paso esta agrupación
libertaria no podría sumar mucho más que
unos 40 diputados y ocho senadores esto
por supuesto le dejaría muy lejos de
poder controlar un congreso compuesto
por un total de 72 senadores y 257
diputados sí la suma de libertad avanza
y Juntos por el cambio tendría una
mayoría muy clara pero mi ley tendría
que negociar y lo tendría que hacer No
solo con un único partido sino con una
fuerza legislativa en Argentina suele
ser bastante heterogénea aunque los
candidatos se presenten por una misma
plataforma como Juntos por el cambio
suele haber muchas corrientes diferentes
La pregunta es sería Miley capaz de
negociar y llegar a acuerdos con la
oposición
[Música]
pues lo cierto es que el mismo tiene
dudas de que ese proceso pudiera llegar
a buen Puerto sobre todo con lo que
respecta a las grandes reformas Eso sí
dice tener un plan me comprometo frente
a la población dolarizar Y si la casta
política no me lo deja hacer
llama un referéndum vas a ver lo que
dice la gente el candidato libertario ha
dicho que recurriría a las consultas
populares y no solo en el caso de la
dolarización sino también para otras
muchas políticas incluyendo temas de
alto voltaje Como por ejemplo la
legalización del aborto Esto es algo que
despierta ciertas inquietudes no solo
dentro del entorno político sino que
también existen serias dudas sobre el
encaje jurídico de esta acción y es que
aquí la ley una ley que no podría
cambiar sin el acuerdo con la oposición
parece bastante claro la ley de
convocatoria consulta popular vinculante
deberá tratarse en una sesión especial y
ser aprobada con el voto de la mayoría
absoluta de miembros presentes en cada
una de las cámaras es decir el futuro
presidente mi ley solo podría convocar
sin aprobación legislativa previa
referéndums No vinculantes sí podría
presentar un referéndum ganarlo Y
entonces presionar al congreso pero
tener una cosa Clara esto generaría
mucha muchísima tensión Y no sólo eso
tampoco sería un proceso particularmente
rápido
[Música]
amigos mi ley está creando muchas
expectativas y un posible bloqueo
político podría bien hacerle perder su
proyección política o para intentar
mantener el barco a flote lanzarse al
cuello del legislativo lo que vete tú a
saber cómo termina desde luego no sería
nada bueno Esos son los dos grandes
riesgos que existen porque el problema y
lo hemos visto en otros países de
América Latina se produce Cuando un
presidente crea muchas expectativas y
luego no tiene apoyo real para llevar a
cabo los cambios prometidos insisto esto
no quiere decir que mi ley no podría
llegar a salirse con la suya por ejemplo
logrando un gran acuerdo conjuntos por
el cambio utilizando inteligentemente lo
referéndums no vinculantes para en dos
años incrementar su peso legislativo lo
que queremos decir es que el riesgo de
que no lo consiga y que eso tenga
consecuencias está sobre la mesa
Especialmente cuando hablamos de un
candidato que no es partidario de Buscar
muchos entendimientos ese sentaría con
ella hablar de una transición si Le
tocará ganar no y con Alberto Fernández
tampoco
[Aplausos]
Claro que amigos amigas quizás haya algo
o alguien que Estamos perdiendo de vista
un perfil que últimamente actúa entre
bambalinas y que en un futuro no muy
lejano puede tener un rol clave en toda
esta historia estamos hablando por
supuesto del mismísimo Mauricio macri es
obvio que pienso que vamos a ir a una
segunda vuelta con esta nueva expresión
más liberal más rupturista y de enojo de
esta frustración que arrastra Argentina
hace años el candidato de Juntos por el
cambio que está en esa posición tendrá
que demostrar que más allá de las
intenciones rupturistas y de cambio que
tiene mi ley nosotros tenemos las mismas
pero con experiencia y Eso debería
inclinar la balanza a favor nuestro el
expresidente argentino no sólo tuvo una
premonición hace meses sobre la ola
libertaria sino que desde hace tiempo ha
entablado una cercanía particular con el
propio Javier milei Hasta tal punto que
el año pasado el líder libertario
planteaba esta posibilidad macri Podría
tener un rol muy importante
en trabajando en conjunto con la
cancillería si ella digamos quisiera
venir a nuestro espacio digamos esta
sería bien recibida ministra de digo
podría ser hasta jefe de gabinete Claro
que las elecciones y el combate
electoral suelen crear muchas fracturas
sea como sea macri podría ser la llave
para buscar una agenda de reformas
conjunta pero por ahora si algo está
claro es que mi ley propone reformar la
Argentina de arriba a abajo y que ahora
por primera vez sí que tiene muchas
probabilidades de terminar siendo el
nuevo presidente de la Argentina los
riesgos y las oportunidades están sobre
la mesa Y a partir de ahí ya sabéis no
tenemos ninguna bola de cristal pero
llegados hasta aquí la pregunta es para
ti qué opinión tienes de Javier milei
Qué te parece su programa político crees
que realmente terminará siendo el nuevo
presidente de la Argentina déjanos tus
impresiones abajo en los comentarios y
abramos debate y ahora si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante ya sabéis no
olvidéis darle al botón de like bien
fuerte y suscribiros a visualpolitik si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]